please welcome back the incredible jamie
oliver
thank you
food
food's a beautiful thing and i think the
lovely thing about food is that if you
just allow yourself to go on a journey
it's the most fantastic thing as i've
traveled around the world the best food
has never come from the richest
communities never
always it's always come from the poorest
communities when they know the knowledge
of cooking
and i guess that's what i'm trying to do
just teach people that the currency is
knowledge and that's why i write these
books you know with together i wanted to
basically make you kind of re-look at
the concept of togetherness after the
last two years right together doesn't
mean the same does it like to be with
each other to laugh to joke to hug you
know all of that stuff so
if i may yes that's that's that's part
of my family on the front the teenagers
wouldn't come anywhere near me
but every chapter in the book this is
the first time i've ever done it it's a
meal and in this meal there's fancy
meals there's humble meals there's taco
parties curry nights there's like this
this what i'm gonna do now is like a
last minute feast like when you gather
your friends together last minute and
you want to go to a small supermarket a
corner store and and you can put this
thing together super quick let me show
you something
i'm going to teach you this is this is
something
that
like literally my 10 year old kid does
he loves it um if you go to the
supermarkets right they'll be packs of
fresh lasagna sheets right now what's
good about those is you can cut it up
any way you want tagliatelli papadely la
zenyetti whatever shape you want it
doesn't matter right the point is you
have an opportunity to cheat and be
creative so if you get your sheet and
you can just roll it up let me get that
out of the way for you thank you just
roll it up like that and cut it into one
centimeter slices now if you go thicker
obviously you get the papadelli even
thicker little lasagnetti you can do
like all kinds of shapes and sizes
the best thing is this only takes three
minutes to cook so if you're talking
about speed now we're going to get
exciting so we've got boiling water here
we're just going to take a bowl a heat
proof bowl put that on a bowl
that'll help the water boil anyway how's
that doing drew i'm i was going too thin
and then i saw your name
when when it's all different shapes and
sizes when you do it wrong it's right
okay if it all looks perfect it looks
like something from a factory and that
ain't homemade right so get this exactly
grab this in your hands and just give it
a little shake and see what you've got
beautiful look at that
i know so we've got some almonds some
parmesan a little cream some chili some
mint some lemon you can mix up the herbs
you can mix up the nuts right make it
your own but we've pounded up some nuts
in your pestle and water when you bash
it up fine it goes creamy it's also
protein a really healthy protein we can
literally take a few bits of mint this
is the power of herbs right so literally
five leaves it could be basil it could
be mint it could be parsley pound that
up if we want to give it a nice little
pungency with garlic
purp garlic clove in there as well so
we've got the garlic gourmet girl and
then we can also have a little heat a
little heat
a little heat i like it a little heat
and then you've taught me to make sure
to cut the stems out obviously according
to absolutely your heat preference yeah
if you take the seeds away from the
chili you get rid of most of the heat
and you're left with the fruit a much
more subtle chili flavor we're now going
to get this into that bowl so we're not
going to really boil this sauce right
we're just going to heat it through and
then what's really nice as well we often
use the lemon juice the zest is really
powerful it's got an amazing essential
oils and again two little strokes of
mint
you'll probably start smelling it in a
second right it's absolutely incredible
so we've got that going i'm going to
show you how quick this sauce is just a
little swig of cream just a little sweet
just regular cream goes in
cream
so cream goes in the parmesan goes in
and that is a very simple basic sauce it
doesn't need to be boiled it doesn't
need to be overcooked like the heat can
you see the steam coming up so what i
want you to do drew and be careful
because we love you very much take your
little tea towel
and we'll just take that bowl off
and we'll throw this pasta in this pasta
only takes three minutes to cook fresh
pasta is like almost instantaneous to
the water it's fragrant and i think like
this is the kind of thing that i would
knock up you know if you want to add
things to it like leftover chicken you
can have some fun with that sometimes uh
one of my kids likes prawns in it but i
like it simple like this i use the tongs
you can drain it if you want but i quite
like using the tongs and as we toss the
pasta in that sauce can you see how it's
just thickening up the pasta's sucking
up the sauce but look this is the pasta
here we'll just finish that
that's it
there we go i love a good plating and
you know make it look restaurant style
would you like me to feed you oh my god
or would you like it yeah
come on let's do it and
that's it there you go
simple
delicious
elegant
and you can start and finish that in
five minutes five minutes
i just think this book is so amazing and
it's gonna go in my collection of every
single cookbook you've ever made so get
jamie's latest and greatest together is
out now and you can check out his show
also titled together on pbs check your
local listings for air times
[Music]
you